nato rial voici l'histoire de six
français moyen adepte d'internet qui à
des fins privées je le précise
télécharger de ci de là sur leurs
ordinateurs des jeux vidéo des films et
de la musique et qui ensuite les graver
sur cd
cet après midi ils seront jugés par le
tribunal de senlis poursuivi par tous
les grands producteurs d'hollywood il ya
la fox paramount warner disney c'est un
nouvel épisode donc de la fable sur le
combat entre le pot de terre et le pot
de fer jérôme soûlard djilali bellaïd
philippe buisson et son épouse ne
s'attendait certainement pas à être
traînés devant les tribunaux
leur faute comme des millions
d'internautes français c'est d'avoir
téléchargé de la musique et des films
un millier de ces des illégaux retrouvés
à leur domicile pour un usage personnel
qui pourrait pourtant leur coûter cher
cent cinquante mille euros damende deux
ans de prison tout ça pour arriver à
n'importe qui on n'a pas de moyens
important aujourd'hui pour se défendre
face à ce type de l'accusation et sans
avoir eu le sentiment de faire quelque
chose de très mal on est on est un peu
considérés comme des criminels et un
petit clic pour une grosse amende car
depuis quelques mois les grandes majors
du film et de la musique ne laisse rien
passer
les professionnels portent plainte
contre les pirates on veut faire des
exemples pour limiter la fraude tout ça
évidemment c'est une histoire de gros
sous sont des pertes très importantes
et encore une fois vous avez un exemple
in vitro de l'effet de l'impact de la
contrefaçon numérique dans les chiffres
qui ont été régulièrement publiés depuis
plusieurs trimestres par l'industrie
mini musicales qui font apparaître un
déclin certains pourtant la justice n'a
pas toujours donné raison à l'industrie
du disque
la semaine dernière à cahors le tribunal
correctionnel a ainsi relaxé un jeune
internaute qui avait copié illégalement
500 cd mais lui il est réservé à son
usage personnel qu'il ne faisait ni
échange ni commerce
on en a parlé